okay there's this idea in the background
that I've mentioned that more and more
of the Christopher steel Trump blackmail
dossier is accurate and you'll remember
that when we initially heard about this
Russian blackmail file as it's been
colloquially called the position from
Trump and his associates was the dossier
doesn't exist well then we learned that
actually the dossier exists that both
Obama and Trump were briefed on the
dossier by the American intelligence
community but that the content of the
dossier is all fake and of course it
turns out that actually a lot of the
content of the dossier is true there's a
really good document on the just
security website by John cipher kind of
a funny name for someone who writes on a
security website whose last name is
cypher like decipher even though it's
spelled differently si PHP are John
ciphers a former CIA senior intelligence
service operative and he did something
really interesting he went back and
reviewed the Russia dossier not in the
context of what we knew when it leaked
but based on what we now know and you'll
remember that at the time that the
dossier leaked defenders of Trump
insisted it's unproven it's speculative
it's unverified it's rumors it's gossip
it's fake it's irresponsible to even
discuss it but over time over the last
several months we've learned that more
and more of the content of the dossier
actually is true and cypher points out
some really important elements that we
should keep in mind number one when you
produce this type of document within the
intelligence community you're not
delivering it to people on the basis
that the contents are 100% accurate
you're delivering it on the basis that
these are assertions that are out there
these are things that have been alleged
and then you consider each statement you
consider the credibility of the author
in this case a highly respected former
British intelligence operative named
Christopher Steele and over time we've
learned that so much of what's in the
dossier is true before it was publicly
acknowledged the reports that served as
the base information for the dossier
alleged that Russia undertook a massive
coordinated effort to disrupt the 2016
election to help Donald Trump that's now
the consensus very few now too
I bet reports that make up the steel
dossier alleged with pretty specific
facts issues related to meetings
involving Paul Manafort and Trump
affiliates with Russia to discuss stolen
documents that turned out to be true the
dossier alleged that Trump had
long-standing involvement with Russia
including to explore business deals that
turns out to be true
the reports alleged that Trump campaign
associates had repeated contact with
senior Russian officials in the year
before the election we now know that to
be true we learned that when Carter page
travelled to Moscow in July of 2016
he met with Igor Sechin a later Steel
report also claimed that he met with
other Russian associates and we've since
learned that those assertions are true
the documents referred repeatedly to all
the money that Paul Manafort was getting
off the books from the Ukrainian
presidents pro-russian party for example
that's absolutely true
the documents alleged that there were
meetings between trumps lawyer Michael
Cohen and Russians that was initially
categorically denied by Cohen we've
since been able to independently
corroborate relationships with Russian
and Ukrainian intermediaries and Michael
Cohen and we've learned about Michael
Cohen's direct contact with Felix aider
via email
to try to do a Trump Tower Moscow every
day or week more of the dossier is
verified that's not to say that the
Christopher Steele dossier is free from
inaccuracies there are a few but it
doesn't take away from any of the major
points and it's not like Steele was
trying to deceive very credible source
and I mean some of that's just
inevitable when you talk about
intelligence reporting you're never
gonna get it completely accurate and for
me the most interesting thing from John
ciphers analysis was anybody who is
going to point to any inaccuracy to say
the entire thing is unreliable or
untrustworthy doesn't understand the
point of such a document it's the report
on assertions that have been made not
necessarily having verified every single
one and listen does Trump have a urine
fetish involving Russian prostitutes
maybe not although by the way John
cipher says it wouldn't be that
inconsistent with what we know about
Trump's sexual past include
stories he's told on the Howard Stern
Show but it doesn't matter that does not
in any way impact the general
credibility of the dossier Trump also
knew that the Obama slept on that bed
once when they visited Russia so maybe
he just wanted to defile the bed and
doesn't really have any sexual interest
to begin with I I would not even dare
comment on that but I think anything is
on the table as far as that goes and a
really really interesting read which we
are linking to John ciphers explanation
or analysis of the Russia dossier in the
description for the YouTube video for
this story okay send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at the Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show today's
program is sponsored in part by live
lingua which is an immersive language
learning platform where you're actually
learning from native speakers you might
recall I've mentioned that on the show I
am someone who was born speaking Spanish
in Argentina and I learned English as a
Second Language
I've studied both French and Hebrew as
non native languages and learning from
native speakers speaking with native
speakers is the most effective way to
get the language proficiency that you
want live lingua will match students
with personal teachers to work
one-on-one on their language learning
goals
no trendy gimmicks no promises to make
you fluent in a month by practicing five
minutes a day live lingua is an online
language immersion school that works
with students aged four to ninety four
students work one-on-one with their
teachers meaning there's no falling
behind the rest of the class all classes
are taught by native speakers of the
language who also speak English and it
costs a fraction of what a private tutor
would charge you know spending time in
traffic commuting to classes your tutor
comes to you via Skype and for our
viewers and listeners you can get a free
trial Skype lesson by visiting live
lingua com slash Pakman live linguist
personal class coordinator will contact
you arrange a lesson that fits into your
schedule with the teacher that's best
suited to your ability and learning
style and then after the trial lesson
you'll receive a full evaluation in a
proposed curriculum person
to your needs if you want to continue
live linguas immersive language learning
method is convenient it's productive
it's built to meet the needs of each
student you can visit live lingua comm
slash Pakman for your free trial lesson